this is bloomberg quick take i'm
scarlett fu
nice work if you can get it say working
alongside dwayne the rock johnson and
ryan reynolds to track down a jewel
thief played by gal gadot yes please my
next guest had the tough task of playing
alongside some of hollywood's top stars
in the new netflix movie red notice
joining us today is actress ritu arya
from london ritu welcome to quick take
thanks for speaking with us today
oh my gosh thank you for having me so i
was reading that rhett notice had the
biggest opening weekend ever for netflix
since this is a streaming film i just
wonder how much access you had to
viewing numbers how granular some of the
data was that you were able to see
i think i'm just sort of seeing what
everyone else is seeing i'm getting
texts from the producer and director
with them
you know
numbers of stuff but yeah it's pretty
crazy
along with big names like the rock like
gal gadot what's notable about the red
notice production was that only half the
filming was completed when
the covid pandemic hit and you guys were
forced to kind of just halt proceedings
completely
and production shut down until i believe
september 2020
what was that interruption like for you
were you stuck in atlanta the whole time
what
happened is we were
on set we'd been shooting for a month
and
um we were told that
we'd have to you know shut down
production and it was
important for us all to go back and see
our families so
we we traveled home and we weren't sure
if we were even going to come back
and so we were really happy that we were
able to you know sort of three or
whatever four months later they said
that we
would be up and running and so
uh then we came back to atlanta and we
were staying in this like nba style
bubble and
it was crazy with all the masks and and
shields
the film i understand was filmed
entirely in georgia on different
production sets using a lot of movie
magic what did what did that whole
experience teach you about the benefits
and perhaps also limitations of cgi and
green screens and and all of that
it's pretty amazing that we were able to
shoot a film that's set all across the
world
just in one studio
um
and amazing watching it back
and seeing these moments that i thought
was filming there's no way this is gonna
look
like i'm looking over a cliff
i was just standing on the ground and i
was like looking at my shoes and then
you see the film and it looks like i'm
looking off a cliff it's crazy they're
just like very impressed um every day
with what might this what might the
studio look like because you felt like
you were going to a museum in rome to
like
the argentinian jungle it was
amazing what they could do absolutely
ritu thank you so much for sharing your
time with us ritu arya is star of the
netflix original red notice as well as
the drummer in the band kin